day 10 um
naked uh trying to pull
his own testicles off
in certain things up his back passage
refusing any medication um
covered in excrement rubbing it in his
eyes his ears
and been like that for about three days
[Music]
what was your impression of the first
time you go into the prison in your it's
your first day
the first time i did go in terrifying
walking down main street um there were
lots of prisoners about
at that time i didn't know where they
were going straight up in your face one
lad straight up in my face
you know who you think you are put a few
expletives in there just challenging you
straight away
you know you didn't know where to put
your face you didn't know where to look
yeah i'm a big lad worked on the doors
or whatever but
you know totally out of my comfort zone
it was uh
terrifying to say the least what was the
time you were most scared
forest bank i remember two lads i had a
altercation with i was on with a very
young new
officer in the morning these two lads
had wanted to go in the same cell
together
and i i said they could however one of
them
um it made me ask me 40 times that day
and he'd become abusive
so i said no it's not happening now you
know i'd overstep the mark
that's that's all it was um
evening duty we just unlocked
and we were saving meals
i i just you know i was literally stood
turning back
he threw the towel around starts choking
me out i don't know if you've never been
choked out and it is a terrifying
experience
any of you to watch fighting ufc
when people are in chokes inevitably
you know the vast majority tap out your
body goes into
panic mode the other lad was punching
kicking me i shouted at the
new officer to press the alarm bell she
went to the end of the wing let herself
off the wing left the gates open
and handed the keys in she was gone she
never came back the ladder was trying to
kick and punch me
you know it wasn't really concerned to
me it was a fact i was getting choked
out two of the cleaners
den and ben bless him um came over
one of the cleaners pressed the alarm
bell and the two cleaners sorted these
two lads out
as it were so if it hadn't been for them
i would have got a good kick in
so the case of the cleaners they're
they're actual prisoners prisoners are
employed
um both at forest bank in strange ways
usually
tough lads you know um
who get on with the jail you know polite
helpful but tough lads
some some of the people you're gonna see
in a day murdered another person
is that a strange thing to go through to
be honest when i first started
you don't know what anyone's in for you
don't necessarily look what people are
in for so
i started on the young offenders which
was 18 to 21 year olds
very violent community it wasn't until
probably
six months in that i did a
escort to a hospital in liverpool and
it was a four officer escort which is
unusual that
usually most hospital escorts will be
two or three so this guy was obviously a
risk and i'd look on the computer
to see what he was in for he had broke
into
a pensioners home some guy in his
eighties
and this is a lad who's 1819.
he'd robbed him he'd killed him and then
he had visited the premises for
several weeks um
committing sexual acts on this guy that
he killed
so postmortem that lad
wasn't on that wing very long he went to
the gym one day
someone found out what he'd done um i
remember the lad
and he hit him with a dumbbell in the
face
he went to hospital and i never saw him
again
so but that was the first time i'd ever
looked
at what anyone was in for and you know
obviously that's quite shocking
so is it hard not to resent
prisoners who've been there for violent
crimes a lot a lot of it
is our people present and now they are
with you um
we had lots of violent prisoners child
killers on the healthcare sadly
who you know were not problematic
we never clashed you know because
someone was a child killer i didn't take
a personal dislike to him
a lot of people say how could you work
with people like that well if you're
doing the job
you know i chose to go and work on the
healthcare and they're sort of people
who are going to be working with
but quite often it's how they present so
if someone just gets on with it
gets on with the jail you know is polite
with the nursing staff
you know people call me what they like
but people who are rude and abusive to
the nursing staff
won't tolerate that was there ever a
prisoner who
creeped you out who i got under your
skin yeah it was
well i hated really i disliked our mark
bridger when i worked on healthcare
come from little village in wales and
took april jones bless her
and killed her and
did unmentionable things to her
i've tried to explain before you know
other prison officers have said to me
you've got too
close or whatever or when i worked on
the healthcare and he was on there yeah
he's high-profile prisoner i was sat at
home in water in manchester the misses
said
will this guy be coming to you he was on
telly he'd been made
cat a prisoner so he's gonna strange
ways a new nature of his offense would
be on the healthcare and when i got
there he was there
working every day with somebody like
that seeing how they behaved
trying to manipulate people and staff
and a lot of them it's all about them
you know the offense because he's high
profile
very difficult to deal with i just
definitely
hated that guy you said that there were
the incidents that stuck with you
most in your career happened in this
mental health
wing yeah what were those incidents um
we had a lad talks about this guy a lot
he
probably in his 40s been to prison three
or four times
so he came into prison he was medicated
came to the healthcare
he was well known to us and at times
have been incredibly unwell
the psychiatrist was looking at his
medication and he told him that he'd
been on it too long
and he was going to change it he told
him the combination
the psychiatrist wanted to put him on
um didn't work for him and if he tried
to do that he would stop taking his meds
so the psychiatrist changed his meds he
stopped taking his meds
so day one yeah he had a
scruffy leather jacket he always used to
wear we had a game of pull
he said he was going to stop taking his
meds you could have a conversation with
this guy
you know he was educated and
he was a nice lad a pleasant lad to talk
to
day 10 and naked
trying to pull his own testicles off
in certain things up his back passage
refusing any medication um
covered in excrement rubbing it in his
eyes his ears
and been like that for about three days
desperate i would say desperate and
you know it was just it's not pleasant
he
went to hospital i think day 11
on an emergency section so yeah
10 days from functioning adult
um chatty plain pool to
naked and harmony himself
how can you not if you've got any
humanity be affected by that
seeing somebody like that do you think
that
events like that i've had a long-term
impact on you probably
on the mental health side working on
health care strange ways and
you know there was quite a few people
who were mentally unwell at forest bank
seeing people at the lowest unmedicated
and that's probably had the biggest
impact
you know because you you see things
normal people don't see
sometimes in a car crash moment
and they're the sort of things that
haunt me
if you like i have instances like that
impacted your mental health i
in 2004 so
you know it's like 17 years ago but it's
like it was yesterday
i was angry with the prison service i
wasn't treated well when i was on the
sick
procedures weren't followed um
i put myself through five months of
psychology with salford mental health
services who were amazing the
psychologist i saw
having nightmares brain not shutting
down
my doctor was super supportive tried me
on various meds
which did not suit me at all
things come into med regular now they
don't affect me as much
um i'm a lot calmer um if i don't sleep
at night like last night because i was
coming down london driving down london
you know
i got up i know i'm tired i'm you know
i'm quite relaxed and calm or whatever
but
it definitely impacts um
lots of my friends have left i've seen
officers
good officers who've been in a job a
long time one incident
one incident finished a career in case
you're thinking ask it no i don't regret
anything i've ever done i won't change
anything i'd do everything
that i have done exactly the same um
you know it's just part of my life
experience as it were
we don't rehabilitate people in prison
yeah
we're not giving them the tools the care
or anything like that all we're good at
doing is keeping them locked up
when does an ex-con become an ex-con
and that's when he chooses to
as as from two days ago it's not it's
under 118 so 118 babies that have been
born and i presently have
14 ladies pregnant at the moment